Brian Wynn horse senior NBA reporter
from ESPN and longtime Cavs beat rod or
joining me here back on the show how you
been Brian hey rich how's it going I'm
fine game three was different why well a
couple of reasons one the casket their
threes and I wish I could give you more
analysis than that but it's really
important someday a territory is more
important than maybe any other team in
the league because it just covers for
all their sins and they also played with
more aggression defensively but I kind
of think that only kept up because they
hit their threes because if they had
been missing them based on the way they
they played all year they probably would
have let their guard down how about the
Celtics were a little bit too nonchalant
you know they'd won seven of the last
eight games and they I don't think came
in with the same intensity that you'd
have to win with a road playoff game
they haven't been good on the road so
it's not really that big of a surprise I
guess but I'm expecting the Cavs to not
shoot as well from three and the Celtics
to play with a lot more intensity
tonight I think tonight will probably be
a extremely important game in the series
well in terms of intensity the Cavs
absolutely ratcheted up I mean the
numbers support what you said Brian 76%
of Celtic shots were contested in Game
three compared to 58% in the previous
two games I mean isn't that I know you
say they nine threes but isn't that also
want to I mean where what well how does
a team dip like that and then suddenly
raise up as the Cavs did best you can
tell with this team I know I'm telling
you rich it's the making of the threes
affects their entire mood so you know
let me just give you some evidence of
that in Game two for example their Cavs
up by eight points in the first half and
they were up by 12 when they allowed to
like free Celtics basket but they played
a really good first half a selfish shot
under 40 percent the Cavs shot 7 of 14
and on threes in the first half of Game
two they were really into the game
really you know educate as you executing
their defensive game plan
2nd half 3 of 17 they completely lay
down defensively the Celtics to 50% they
win the game I'm not saying it's it's
all necessarily on on on just to making
those shots but it it helps the rest of
their team stay engaged they have a they
have an ability to let go of
and the something said by the way have
an effect on that they're not missing
those trees in a vacuum they contested
really well in good spurts and those
games in Boston but you know there's
also been some defensive adjustments I
don't know how much accident knows you
really want to get into but you know one
of the things that the Cavs really have
noticed as a Jalen Brown when he has a
good first quarter he tends to have a
good game offensively when he doesn't he
doesn't and so instead of having Kyle
Korver or JR Smith on him
they put LeBron on him to start Game
three and LeBron was very aggressive and
into him they changed the way that they
have defended Al Horford which is a
really important factor in this but all
in all I thought like Terry Rozier who's
from Cleveland and I thought he was way
too jacked up I thought he was taking
some shots out of sequence I thought
that hurt the Celtics too there's a lot
of little things but big picture when
you go 17 to 34 year the Cavs their
offense is so potent when they're making
those shots they're gonna win those
games so Bronwyn Hearst here on ESPN if
we know it then Brad Stevens definitely
knows that what do you think the
adjustments from the Celtics are gonna
be for Game four this evening yes so I
think Brett's teams probably spent the
last 36 hours thinking about how to get
Al Horford freedom so in the first game
of the series the cab came out there
they started Kyle Korver and Kevin
love's love it Center and the Celtics
attacked Kevin Love in pick-and-roll I
think they put 41 picks pick and rolls
on him and Horford just ate them up cuz
Horford is a tremendous distributor he
can put the whole ball more and so the
second start in the second game he was
using Tristan Thompson on and moved him
in the starting lineup and then they
used a Larry Nance who's in my opinion
their best offensive player as the
backup on Horford and Horford has had a
much less impact these last two games he
had a really good second half in Game
two but to me the first half of Game two
in all of Game three not effective so
I'm expecting a possible lineup change
for Brad Stevenson i he may bring Aron
Baynes into the starting lineup and try
to make it a little bit harder for
Richardson Thompson to just stay on Al
Horford and move them in some actions
but even if they doesn't change the
lineup I expect there to be some
maneuvers to try to get Tristan Thompson
off of Al Horford so he can get more
involved again offenses front
worst of ESPN here on the Rich Eisen
show in the Western Conference Finals
give me the blueprint for Houston win
three out of the last four is their one
hope that Steph Curry and Kevin Durant
gets food poisoning Wow I don't know
that that's feasible Brian that's a
tough one to pull off right yeah I mean
you have to have an Inside Man so if
they've got that in the in the portfolio
now's the time when when this when they
when the Warriors have an engaged game
and what I mean by that is a game where
they're not throwing the ball into the
third row because they're just not
concentrating and they work and work
their habits defensively they're as
close to as an unbeatable team as I've
ever seen and I don't really want to get
into the conversation of greatest of all
time let's just say that the game of
basketball has never been played at a
higher level than then by this team when
they're playing this way and it's not
that ridiculous of a thought I mean go
tell me the last time a team has had two
MVPs in their prime playing on the same
team
it just has never happened I know that
Pippen and Jordan were probably pretty
close but the tip he's my colleague at
ESPN I'm not denigrating he was never an
MVP they have two MVPs in their primes
playing together and I don't know
whether it's good for the NBA you know
you talk to certain people in the league
and and they have skin in the game so
it's hard for them to have perspective
but they will tell you that the salary
cap spike that made it feasible for the
Warriors to sign Kevin Durant was one of
the worst thing that's happened the
league in the last 20 years in terms of
competitiveness and I think people love
watching the Warriors and the league in
general is being watched very very
widely the ratings are very strong so
maybe people from the league would say
that having a juggernaut team is
actually good for the league but in
terms of competitiveness those two guys
together and the Warriors ability to
keep them together which it looks like
they have a good chance of doing it so
it's taking a wrecking ball to
competitive balance and the Warriors oh
no apologies they worked within the
rules and they were prepared and they
had some fortune coming their way and
things sell for them but putting those
two guys in the same team and last night
you saw them they both played well I
don't know what the antidote is for you
know short of soup or
Wow I mean then if we're talking about
if we're talking real talk here which we
clearly are
if LeBrons Cavs don't win three out of
the next four in the Eastern Conference
then a Celtics team now there is a large
Celtics fan base obviously
coast-to-coast but a Celtics fan be a
team without a bona fide superstar would
be starring in the Eastern Conference
Finals against the Warriors you don't
think there would be a ratings hit for
something like that
Oh it'll be a rating set but I don't
know how competitive you think it would
be more competitive now I know that
that's what I'm saying it's just yeah
it's just when when you sit here and you
basically say that a 65 win team needs
food poisoning helped to get past a
two-time champion of the league
including the defending champion and
then the two teams that they would be
facing in the championship are so flawed
that they really wouldn't have a shot to
me that is bad for league Brian I'll be
honest with you yeah I mean I would say
I remember saying this back in 2016 to
Cavs fans who were frustrated they were
facing maybe losing two files in a row
and I basically said you have to run out
the ground ball against the Warriors
unfortunately the ground ball is being
hit to Ozzie Smith in his prime but you
got to run off the ground ball because
you never know what will happen and in
that case if you did so what I would say
that the Celtics are cab should they
advance I would say you know you got it
you got to jump through every hoop and
you got to turn every corner you're
gonna run out every ground ball but I
mean let's just be honest where this
week is when the Warriors are fully
healthy yeah I don't think someone's
taken four out of seven off of them and
you know in 2016 some circumstances
happened not only the great draymond
Green suspension which was key but also
Andrew Bogut who was there really
important defender for them at the time
hurt his knee and got knocked out in the
last two-and-a-half game so you know
things happen you yeah I'm not saying
don't turn the TV on I mean you watch it
but in terms of like a competitive
series I don't foresee that which is
stronger this Warriors team is and
frankly I felt that way for a long time
now they got off track and I think one
of the I think maybe their their biggest
weakness the Warriors biggest weakness
is
is a lethargy and that's one thing that
Steve Kerr was fighting all season long
trying to keep these guys engaged just
pulling his air out doing every trick in
the book you know camping him over to
the handing him over the clipboard
letting him run Huddle's because they
just and then and they had some injuries
but none of their injuries were severe
so you know that's what you stopping
them is lethargy and injuries and right
now they're not lethargic nor are they
injured and that's devastating for
anybody who's playing against Brian
loved the chat we'll chat during the NBA
Finals okay I love that have a good day
you gotta that's Brian one more set win
horst ESPN the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience